[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour un nouveau
numéro du 7-8 sport votre magazine
consacré à l'actualité sportive dans le
département c'est parti pour le sommaire
rugby y est avec une nouvelle déconvenue
pour le sky rugby alors qu'ils avaient
bien lancé la rencontre les saint
quentinois se sont inclinés face à
bagneux
score final 16 à 7 les détails dans
cette édition
12e édition de l'eco-trail cette course
de 80 kilomètres entre l'île de loisirs
de saint quentin en yvelines et la tour
eiffel nos deux invités se sont lancés
dans cette épreuve fabien parmentier et
sidy diallo seront avec nous et nous
raconteront leurs courses
sidy diallo reviendra aussi sur sa
performance hors norme sept marathons
réalisé en 7 jours puis nous recevrons
un record man andy cabreira il se lance
un nouveau défi ce samedi 24 mars durant
six heures enchaîner des passages en
apnée les plus long possible
un record pour sensibiliser aux dallas
défense des animaux marins on commence
tout de suite avec la page résultats
[Musique]
nouvelle défaite du sky rugby sur ses
terres dans le cadre de la 15e journée
de championnat honneur
les saint quentinois se sont inclinés
sur le score de 16 à 7 face à bagneux
aucune conséquence sur le classement
puisqu'ils sont assurés du maintien et
ne jaune où ils ne vont pas jouer la
montée cette saison récit de la
rencontre sur un montage de romain russe
fini il ne fallait pas arriver en retard
pour cette rencontre entre le sky rugby
et bagneux
dès l'entamé les saint quentinois mettre
la pression sur leurs adversaires
et s'il se loupe une première fois la
seconde est la bonne on joue la deuxième
minute de jeu et le sky mène déjà 7 à 0
le premier quart d'heure est sous
domination saint-quentinoise le sky news
by campent dans les 22 mètres adverses
sans réussir à inscrire le moindre point
ce qui a manqué je pense que c'est
effectivement de marquer un deuxième
essai un programme mi-temps on avait
l'occasion de marquer un deuxième essai
de prendre d'autres disent nos distances
on l'a pas fait et après lui tendent à
une belle équipe en face qui a
expérimenté en honneur qui était pendant
le match au début qui est rentré dans le
match au fur à mesure donc résultat nous
on se retrouve on se retrouve derrière à
la fin on va dire logiquement puisque on
n'était pas loin mais ils ont maîtrisé
qu'à la deuxième mi temps
ben il revient en inscrivant un essai
tout en mouvement tout en puissance
mais les giboulées de mars invite dans
la partie le ballon se transforme en
savonnette les en avants se multiplient
les visiteurs réussissent tout de même à
passer devant 8 à 7 à la mi temps
au retour des vestiaires le sky rugby
commet beaucoup de fautes les balles
néolait en profite et prennent le large
en marquant un deuxième essai les points
n'évolueront plus score final 16 à 7
pour les visiteurs dans la tête on
n'était pas trop ça fait trois semaines
qu'on n'a pas joué et il faut se
remettre dedans il faut se remettre un
peu pour se remettre à rythme de matchs
de championnat quoi cette défaite n'a
aucune incidence au classement 7e le sky
rugby est assuré du maintien
il reste trois matches aux saint
quentinois avant la fin de la saison il
reste invaincu cette saison et en plus
ils décrochent leur ticket en division
supérieure lors de cette 15e journée
grâce à leur victoire à l'année 8 à 3 le
rugby-club de versailles a sur sa montée
en fédérale 3 la saison prochaine
les versailles en 17 points d'avancé sur
le second une avance qui les rendent
inatteignable écoutez la réaction du
responsable de la communication du club
pierre chevallier
juste après la descente en 2000 c'est
justement d'avoir de retrouver le niveau
qu'on a qu'on avait vu pendant neuf
saisons d'affilée en termes de
renforcement des quelques quelques
joueurs à des postes et toujours du
rugby autres résultats on division
promotion honneur pour le compte de la
15e journée montigny le bretonneux s'est
imposé sur son terrain face à
chilly-mazarin le score 20 à 0 une ville
qui vit une victoire qui leur permet de
prendre la seconde place du classement
prochain match face à paris xe au rugby
ce dimanche 24 mars football avec le
championnat de régionale 3 trappes n'a
pas décroché n'a décroché que le match
nul sur le terrain de suresnes ce
dimanche 17 mars
les deux équipes se sont neutralisées 1
partout au classement l'étoile sportive
de trappes conserve la première place à
un point de boulogne billancourt
prochain match à domicile face au pecq
faire 80 kilomètres en partant de l'île
de loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
pour rejoindre la tour eiffel le
principe de l'eco-trail la douzième
édition s'est déroulée ce samedi 16 mars
au départ 2006 2007 100 participants et
nos deux invités ont fait cette course
cessons de zinnie montrent un fabien
parmentier bonsoir bonsoir
alors vous vous avez participé à
l'ensemble des échos très depuis sa
création et sidy diallo bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes marathonien vous avez
participé à votre deuxième et cauterets
alors on voit à commencer par l'habituel
fabien parmentier vous avez terminé
l'épreuve en 9 heures 13 minutes et 50
secondes c'est un bon résultat pour vous
c'est pas mon meilleur résultat mais
effectivement ça fait partie de mes
meilleurs chronos voilà ça chante je
suis pas forcément un un as de la compet
je recherche pas forcément la
performance mais pour moi effectivement
sens c'est un temps plus que correct
c'est des conditions auxquelles vous
avez déjà eu à faire ce week-end ou c il
ya eu des conditions un peu exceptionnel
non on n'a pas eu de conditions
exceptionnelles cette année les
conditions exceptionnelles c'était
plutôt l'année dernière avec la neige la
boue le vent la pluie
non cette année c'était une édition
comme y en a eu déjà quelques-unes
entend plutôt plutôt clément et puis et
puis les températures vraiment vraiment
douce donc c'était vraiment une belle
édition
alors vous sidy diallo c'est votre
deuxième participation vous l'aviez déjà
fait en 2016 alors vous comment vous
allez gérer cette course vu que vous
étiez pas trop habitué à l'eco-trail à
la course en elle même si j'en ai fait
un de course de 87 à 90 km sur le
marathon des camarades en afrique du sud
je les fais trois fois des trois pas de
suite et la troisième fois c'était pieds
nus le 10 juin dernier 90 km des plus de
malice moore à durban donc j'ai
l'habitude vous avez la sculpter ses
distances
mais du coup en milieu urbain aussi
c'est 80 kilomètres en milieu urbain un
peu vallonné aussi parce que c'est la
montée puis après on redescend sur
parole comme marrade le marasme des
camarades et extrêmement vallonné il ya
cinq ou line dont le nom vient que
l'évocation de noix sa fait peur et dans
des circonstances très difficiles avec
des ballets des barrières horaires
impitoyable des comptes à rebours
c'est une autre expérience dire que mon
voisin pour essayer de tenter comme l'a
peut-être une dette à noter que l'on
gère lé qu'on al'habitude comment on
gère cette épreuve d cauterets et luz on
change d habitude on change la manière
de s'entraîner on se prépare toujours de
la même manière
alors moi ma manière de m'entraîner je
vais pas en faire la publicité parce que
c'est pas la meilleure comme j'ai déjà
eu l'occasion de le dire sur votre
plateau je suis pas forcément un os de
l'entraînement on va dire je fais le
minimum syndical après voilà on essaye
effectivement avec le temps maintenant
je commence à avoir un petit peu
d'expérience on essaie justement de de
garder comme on dire de faire les bons
choix c'est à dire que j'ai fait
beaucoup d'erreurs maintenant
effectivement les horreurs j'essaie de
ne pas les reproduire
donc tous les ans c'est un peu plus
facile on va dire parce que moi je fais
je fais un petit peu moins d'erreurs et
puis surtout effectivement malgré la
distance et 80 km finalement enfin la
distance sont là prêts en un petit pour
moi on sait que finalement il ya des
idéaux il ya des bas mais finalement ça
passe et puis et puis voilà donc on
essaye de garder ce qui va bien d'une
année d'une année sur l'autre
comment ça s'est passé pour vous par
rapport à 2016 si on prend la
comparaison une promenade
c'est ce qui me fait une promenade avec
à chaussures minimalistes parce que la
forêt
la nuit a fait nous sommes des chasseurs
une espèce de chasseurs cueilleurs met
en chasse le jour et la nuit nous étions
le froid nous courir la nuit dans la
forêt c'est pas naturel pour nous les
humains donc là je les fais avec les
chaussures minimalistes
vous avez l'habitude de courir le
marathon obtenu un village jusqu'aux
pieds nus oui tu peux couleur peut avoir
est cassé le jour je les fais le
marathon de de celle des scènes à 116
dans 7 km dans la forêt de regrets ça je
peux le faire mais pas 80 km pieds nus
et je ne peux pas la nuit surtout on ne
se l'expliqué pas ce que ces différentes
conditions
oui parce qu'en fait quand on est revenu
on a les pieds sur terre au sens propre
comme au figuré
on voit le sol voilà on met les pieds la
nuit dans la forêt sais c'est pas
possible donc j'aurais pu le faire mais
c'était risqué est aisé pas besoin de
l'us kg voilà vous avez fait 11 heures
39 minutes et 33 secondes c'est un temps
satisfaisant pour vous quel que soit le
temps assez satisfaisant fait à ce que
les uns ne travaille pas on est parti
d'ici on a traversé des forêts des
foires et les chasse qui étaient des
forêts les chasses en fait les les
chasseurs mais la prod nous attend au
premier étage de la tour eiffel c'est la
médaille que certains d'accueil tout
cela la médaille la moins bien ils
prennent un défi comme ça est tellement
qu'ils sont contents non c'est en fait
un mort le sport on se trompe
entre palin courses sont plus palema la
tonte repas non c'est une activité
d'inactivité naturels des humains
moi je me suis pris ça comme ça l'erreur
de beaucoup de gens justement c'est à
dire la saison commence je mets préparés
en fait la saison et doit pas s'arrêter
c'était là notre manière de mettre la
main c'est la nourriture
c'était tous les jours puisque tous les
cieux on avait faim et même maintenant
là le bus on dit ben voilà on va courir
quand il fait beau au printemps à
l'automne l'hiver c'est trop froid l'été
s'est lancée la lorraine en fait vous
c'est quoi votre motivation
la démotivation basse et s'est sorti un
petit peu la mode en ce moment en sortir
de ma zone de confort et puis
effectivement
essayer de repousser tout le temps un
petit peu ces mythes alors bon je
rebrousse poil pardon je ne repousse
plus mes limites sur l'éco trail mais du
coup ça me permet de lancer un petit peu
ma saison et puis et puis effectivement
de m'inscrire sur des courses un petit
peu plus longue pour le reste de l'année
quoi alors pour l'édition 2010 9 le
vainqueur c'est benoît corrie que l'on
voit comment avoir à l'image une arrivée
je le rappelle au premier étage de la
tour eiffel comme vous le voyez donc il
a bouclé les 80 km en 5 heures 46
minutes et 24 secondes
un mot sur sur ce temps des extra
terrestres y en a quelques-uns voilà il
y en a encore là je crois qu'il fait
partie des équipes de france de trail
bon ben voilà il ya deux mondes il ya
les élites et puis après il ya le il ya
le peloton comme nous comme sidi comme
moi et puis voilà tant mieux qu'il ya
des personnes comme lui qui nous qui
nous montre un petit peu l'exemple même
si on pourra jamais les égaler alors
avant de conclure ce volet sur les côtes
raides un mot tout de même sur votre
performance idéale aux 7es contre elle
en fait c'était la septième course de la
semaine puisque vous revenez d'une
croisière croisière dans les caraïbes où
vous avez fait plusieurs courses en
guadeloupe sur les îles vierges
britanniques à saint martin la dominique
saint vincent et en martinique
vous avez fait un marathon sur votre
bateau aussi ouais alors vous pouvez
vous raconter un peu cette semaine
oui donc on s'est retrouvé un groupe
d'une quarantaine de personnes des
coureurs et les accompagnateurs
mon épouse elle était avec moi on a
couru le premier à l'ap hm le 8 le vix
marche on a commencé à minuit au bouvier
a
à côté de pointe à pitre et le 8 mars on
est monté si on a pris 1 est monté à
bord d'un des navires avec loisirs y
avait trois mille 3000 personnes
passagers et nous nous étions une
quarantaine et à chaque escale sur
chaque île on courait un marathon 42 km
il est même fait des tours de bateau
aussi voilà maintenant le jour à
naviguer entre pointe à pitre et les
îles vierges britanniques
c'est là c'est là que le pack ou le plus
long donc on est resté toute la journée
en mer et donc ces jours là on a un col
est sur le pont du bateau un mage fm
avec quelques autres on a fait mal à
tous sur la piste de jogging qui fait
que 180 mètres donc ses 235 tour ses
pieds nus sélection performance non plus
tenu à parler de stratégie ce trailer
d'annoncé selon l activité normale à ses
activités de grossiste la course à pied
pour nous les humains c'est l'activité
normale marché c'est une autre moyen de
nous déplacer de tous les jours et
courir c'était le moyen de frapper les
animaux moi je ne fais que ça
sidy diallo merci beaucoup fabien
parmentier merci pour vos témoignages et
on se retrouve pour la 13e édition en
2020 alors voilà le franchissement du
millième km des côtes raides pour ma
part aussi site il ya le jeu promet en
tout cas on vous souhaite une bonne
récupération ça va merci à vous et un
mot de football américain maintenant
avec ces deux statistiques quatre
victoires en quatre matches et zéro
point encaissé c'est le bilan provisoire
affichée par l'équipe des moins de 19
ans des templiers d'elancourt leur
victime du week-end les conquérants de
la ville de caen sur le score de 35 à 0
au classement il devance les molosses
d'asnières sur seine grâce au goal
avérage écouter david pradel
l'entraîneur adjoint faire un point sur
cette première partie de la saison dans
un groupe avec avec des gamins qui
jouent déjà depuis à peu près 3 4 ans
on a de beaux athlètes forcément ça nous
aide à être assez assez compétitive
cette année dernière on a fini en finale
de conférence conférence nord face au
flash de la courneuve sur une défaite
le but maintenant c'est d'aller c'est
d'aller plus loin cette année donc faire
une finale à ce prochain match le 31
mars prochain les templiers d'elancourt
se rendront chez les fox de chantilly et
on ouvre une page cyclisme avec
l'arrivée du paris nice
rappelez vous il ya une semaine les
coureurs ont pris le départ de la course
au soleil depuis saint germain en laye
une épreuve qui s'est achevé hier sur la
promenade des anglais à nice et le
leader colombien de l'équipe sky et
gagnent bernal a remporté cette 77e
édition du paris-nice dimanche 17 mars
il devance son compatriote colombien
nairo quintana de 39 secondes et on
reste sur le vélo avec une légende du
cyclisme français raymond poulidor
étaient présents à la 98e foire
internationale à la brocante à chatou il
a présenté son exposition retraçant sa
carrière et il a dédicacé ses livres
l'occasion pour lui d'échanger avec son
public et les fans de cyclisme
les images sont signés patrick jacques
de dixmude poupou à chatou le célèbre
coureur cycliste français des années 60
raymond poulidor est venu dédicacer ses
livres à la fois international à la
brocante la possibilité pour lui de
rencontrer ses fans on retrace
évidemment un semblant parole l'ensemble
de ma carrière et la conversation
andrien souvent avec jacques anquetil
qui est toujours présent ce fameux duel
avec jacques anquetil est toujours
imposant question comment se fait-il
vous n'avez pas gagné plusieurs tours de
france
c'était ses meilleurs adversaires
jacques anquetil dans les années 60 et
eddy merckx dans les années 70
raymond poulidor avait cette image
d'éternel second mais cette exposition
consacrée à sa carrière mais aussi en
lumière de nombreuses victoires sur le
plan populaire c'est pas c'est pas des
tarnais seront pas s'il a gagné 157
cours sur une basse et une légende mais
c'est un peu le mythe d'un grand coureur
mais qui n'a pas réussi toujours faire
ce qu'il voulait c'est un personnage
un gars courageux qui a pas eu toujours
ma chance dans ces courses cyclistes
bon j'ai encore de la télé qui disait
qu'il était toujours 2e mais non parce
qu'il a quand même gagné pas mal de
choses de milan san remo tour d'espagne
trophée maillot vélo tous les trésors de
poulidor sont à retrouver durant cette
exposition prévue jusqu'au 24 mars à la
foire de chatou et on passe tout de
suite à vous rendez vous sportifs de la
semaine sur notre plateau l'apnéiste
andy cabreira villa nous a rejoint
bonsoir bonsoir
alors on vous surnomme le têtard cubain
déjà pourquoi bon dos des tapas et lyon
et des bleus dit à cuba il était d'être
tout le temps sous l'eau sous l'eau sous
l'eau et donc les moins aisés tard voilà
c'est parce que des petits et toujours
sous le et ce samedi 24 mars vous serez
encore sous l'eau centre aquatique de
saint cyr l'école de 9h à 15h vous
lancer un nouveau défi rester le plus
longtemps possible en apnée pendant six
heures bien sûr en faisant des allers
retours alors est-ce que vous pouvez
nous expliquer comment ça va se passer
alors c'est un record inédit parce qu'il
est personne n'a jamais fait ça c est
resté dans l'âme et statique dieu pas
bougé d'irriter sur place et haricots
consiste à respirer les mois possibles
en six heures
en fait c'est un record symbolique des
symboles hisser la captivité dans
dauphin qui souffrent voilà qui
l'impressionnait davantage donc laisser
les une cage enchaîner des questions de
fond et tout ce que vous que les gens
les tiens c'est pas mon coeur c'est le
message que j'essaie de transmettre
alors est-ce que vous pouvez nous parler
de comment ça va se passer finalement en
fait vous allez être sous l'eau vous
avez pas être en mouvement c'est ça la
ne serait pas le seul à la surface de
l'eau adour palme comme que des dauphins
et lé rôle de dauphin enchaîné pour
symbole et c est donc je profonde
inspiration là dessus et là mais
statique au but deux minutes 2015 2020
je lâche mon père il est prêt inscrits
qui doit être quand même et ré l'étang
d'inspiration ensuite on va à on va
cumuler les tendances pis elle est
retirée à 6 heures et ça va donner les
tendres total d'abonnés ont six heures
alors l'objectif
vous savez combien l'objectif moi c'est
faire des respects mois des dix minutes
en six heures sur leicester minimum 5h50
on apprenait constitution je suppose
qu'il a une énorme préparation derrière
cette performance est plutôt un grand
volonté de transmettre un message pour
que l'agencé moulis et arrêtent des
relais dans la pac à pratiquer pour
visiter les deux frères captivité or
justement qu'en parler après 1,2
de ce côté un peu symbolique comme vous
le dites de mais d'abord sur la
préparation sportive comment vous êtes
préparés à cette épreuve je me vois pas
beaucoup à sec et je suis sur la chaise
de surveillance à la piscine je suis
maître nageur et on a bien souvent il
est public de soi il vient me demander
c'est quoi les codes de sauna est
d'accord en fait vous préparer en
travaillant tous les jours on nous
montrait le minimum une demi-heure sur
la chaise et ça marche
elisa par la chaîne il faut quand même
aller sous l'eau dans la soul aux dons
qu'elle faisait là trois s'entraînement
la première faute majeure
la deuxième fois entre amis et
l'étranger maintenant si cela est là
donc je pense que je suis capable de le
faire c'était aussi aussi alors vous
êtes habitué à faire des performances
symbolique car à côté du sport il ya
l'humain et l'animal aussi que vous
défendez dans cette épreuve là que vous
allez faire samedi 24 mars mais en 2016
déjà vous avez effectué 5 694 longueur
en 6 heures oui et puis en 2017 vous
avait nagé pendant 24 heures dans le
cadre du téléthon pourquoi ces
performances toujours avec un symbole
alors à la fois pour l'humain mais aussi
pour les animaux sauvages parce qu'ils
pensent que les sports c'est sain ça
permet de transmettre des valeurs et
parce qu'elle a valeur de la solidarité
et les très importants ce tout la
société black animaux et il ya toujours
des choses qu'on l'appelle pour le tsl a
donné la vie et donc essaient de
combiner ma passion de la mener pour que
quelque chose qui me tient à coeur
et finalement les résultats c'est gai on
va se réaliser des personnes parce qu'il
ne fait pas tout seul - il faut qu'elle
a menée mais c'est grâce à un travail de
solidarité des beaucoup d'événements
des associations que moi glisse pour que
ces jours là et on puisse aboutir à
notre objectif donc à combiner une
passion avec des délais d altruisme pour
un bien-être à quelqu'un je pense que ce
moment on démarche est alors vous avez
aussi fait une performance je me
souviens c'était par rapport à la
pollution des eaux c'est ça aussi on
taille d'une feuille à six rapports et
les enfants des capelles souvent testé
l'été les taux pour les chansons de
l'océan et aussi pour la journée
mondiale de l'océan
c'était on nommé 18 au mois de juin et
leur accord était de 360 quatre
longueurs j'ai parcouru 3 195 mais je
voudrais souligner les gens aux
plastiques danse sociale
donc j'étais un projet qui est créé de
là à sa survie c'est plus de 500 enfants
ont reçu le diplôme des gardiens des
relations dans le secteur des censiés
l'école voir si fontenay et d'ajouter
des contenus et nos gars sont forts pour
mon record un mois et sur une gt des
plastiques dans l'eau et j'ai nagé dans
l'eau parmi les plastiques comment
c'était un ami fait remarquer voilà qui
est qu'elle souffre de la pollution les
samedi dernier entre une baleine k4 cac
40 kg de plastique dans les ventes
donc elle sait quelque chose d actualité
il faut sensibiliser les gens et là
samedi ce sera pour ce sera contre l'a45
activités et pour la liberté de même
éphémère il faut savoir que la pâte
aquatiques en france marie avec qasmi
femme à la palette et prend les sauvages
whitney ferment là aussi astérix
au total 31 il n'est pas c'est pas
cohérent d'éduquer les enfants d'amour
et respecte la nature et emmener les
enfants au parc optique il faut arrêter
ça il faut que les gens puissent être
avoir la conscience des filles aiment
les animaux de les voir en liberté et
part dans les parcs aquatiques par
exemple astérix n'avait pas chaotique
plus les parcs d'attraction on peut même
assez vite et ça met pas en danger les
arrivées les emplois du parc astérix est
comme ça et du monstre de betty chacun
contre les usa et un jour les enfants et
on dire j'aimerais voir les enfants à
l'ailé
animaux en liberté et voilà c'est ça le
but des ces journées
andy cabreira villa merci d'être venu
sur notre plateau pour nous parler de ce
record que vous avez tenté de réaliser
pour nos téléspectateurs je le rappelle
si vous voulez voir le têtard cubain
tenter ce record rendez vous ce samedi
24 mars à 9h au centre aquatique de
saint cyr l'école
merci encore bon j'ai eu boxeuse
professionnelle depuis 2010 cette marine
tollé de la team farruggia va remonter
sur le ring ce samedi 23 mars à challans
en vendée
son troisième combat au niveau
professionnel ce combat le premier d'une
série de quatre matchs préparatoires
jusqu'au 18 mai prochain et les
championnats de france
marine tôt les connaît déjà son
adversaire hélène lacombe elle veut
profiter de ses combats pour prendre de
l'expérience après un an sans être monté
sur le ring pour combattre
écoutez marine tollé et son entraîneur
temps guy farrugia j'estime que c'est
vraiment un bon défi en arrivant là et
en espérant avoir la ceinture ça sera
déjà quelque chose moi personnellement
une consécration déjà dans mes objectifs
on l'a repris vraiment très sérieusement
à raison d'eux
cinq entraînements par semaine depuis le
janvier 2019 ou la scène a repris sans
un bon rythme mais lâche pas voilà c'est
voilà tant qu'elle est pas ciao même si
en difficulté à lâchera pas l'affairé
un rendez-vous de baseball pour terminer
avec le retour des cougars de montigny
le bretonneux sur le terrain le
lancement de la saison de division une
de baseball lésigny monta affrontent les
niçois cavigal ce samedi 23 et dimanche
24 mars c'est au centre sportif jean
maréchal et petite correction par
rapport à la performance d'andy cabreira
qu'il a ce n'est pas le samedi 24
le samedi 24 mars oui ce sera bien le
dimanche 24 mars à 9h au centre
aquatique de saint cyr l'école c'est la
fin de ce numéro merci de nous avoir
suivis retour lundi prochain de michael
et demi d'euros aux commandes du 7-8
sport
d'ici là passez une excellente semaine
sportive
[Musique]